standby
we are now entering the atmosphere of
venus attention
before the first space programs of the
20th century
it was thought that our closest
neighboring planet may harbor life
i can remember their images where their
dinosaurs and flying dinosaurs
thick clouds covering the surface of
venus caused humanity's imagination to
run wild
and for good reason so at first glance
venus and earth are quite similar
they are about the same size and about
the same mass and in fact sometimes
venus is called our sister planet
but the first probes set by the soviet
union and nasa discovered a world
plagued with a poisonous greenhouse
atmosphere a sweltering surface
temperature and a crushing air pressure
the venusian surface
has a temperature of over
450 degrees celsius so that essentially
melts on the surface of venus it's very
hostile and so attention turned to our
more hospitable neighbor mars
leaving venus largely neglected for
decades
but never forgotten
scientists long speculated that
microbial life could exist in the
permanent cloud layer atmosphere
it turns out that in the upper layers of
the atmosphere between 50 to 60
kilometers above the surface we found
conditions which are not that
different from the surface condition we
find on earth
then in 2020
evidence of biomarkers potential signs
of life were detected in that cloud
layer
maybe the case that microbial life
has adapted has a ball in order to
survive in the high clouds of venus
and although the claim was later
disputed it reinvigorated an enthusiasm
for venus
and scientists are proposing multiple
missions with a single objective
we can just pick one thing and go for it
and we can also
work on the taboo topic of the search
for life
the soviet union's venus missions gave
us the first landings and images of the
surface of another planet
the first audio recordings from the
surface of another planet
and the first and so far the only
planetary balloon missions
balloons have already been flown in the
venusian atmosphere the vega one and two
balloons so we know it works
in 1985 the two spacecraft called vega 1
and vega 2
arrived at venus both equipped with
landers and balloons to explore the
cloud layer atmosphere
the balloons separated from the crafts
lasting more than 46 hours while taking
measurements
the data from that upper cloud layer
differed greatly from the hellish
surface
so the winds have speeds of about 350 or
360 kilometers per hour that's about
the speed of a bullet train and
corresponds to the fastest winds we have
ever measured on earth if we only look
at temperature and pressure the
conditions are very similar to the
surface conditions on earth however the
clouds which on earth consist of water
vapor they're actually made of sulfuric
acid so we are looking for life which
can survive in an extreme environment
[Music]
the cloud layer is estimated to be 50 to
100 times drier than the driest place on
earth the atacama desert in chile
dr armando azu bustos an astrobiologist
and autocoma native has spent much of
his career looking at whether life can
exist in extreme environments
we saw it at the first we would not find
any because it was so dry that is well
there's not any evidence of water here
but if you go like 30 centimeters down
the soil 50 centimeters down and
something like this right
we found a number of microorganisms
which which were still are wondering how
they're able to make it there
these organisms are called extremophiles
life that is adapted to survive in harsh
environments like a desert with no known
water source
that the camera is even as is as dry and
as old as desert as it is
just you can still find life
even in those areas telling you that it
seems that there's no limits for life on
earth and even even in the hearts of
this environment you find life
so if that is possible here how could
that be the same case in other planets
the near sterile environment of the
atacama is normally used as a testing
bed for finding life on mars
but the clouds here could give us clues
about life on venus too
by inspecting the habitability of those
clouds this is just something we're
doing now as we speak
we're trying to understand how that can
also be proposed as an analog model of
the habitabilities of the
high clouds of venusian atmosphere
but the venusian atmosphere isn't just
dry it's extremely acidic
the cave of the lighted house in mexico
contains toxic amounts of sulfuric acid
yet microbial life has evolved to use
other chemical processes to obtain
energy other than photosynthesis
we already have a sample that life was
able to boil and adapt
to the most acidic environment on earth
and you cannot measure a ph lower than
zero it cannot get more acidic than that
so in life was able to
adapt to that environment why could not
be the case if life ever grows in venus
why is it important to understand the
limits for life on earth and how do we
inspect the so-called extreme
environment on earth because that gives
you an idea
on what you may expect on how you should
look for life elsewhere
so it's not easy it's not cheap to go to
mars for example
but i can go to the cama desert which is
a good analog model
while we've been learning a lot about
extremophiles on earth
we've also continued to learn more about
venus since those early missions
now in terms of knowledge of venus today
we know much more about venus such as
about the existing of
prebiotic components such as ammonia
and hydrogen cyanide
we also know that the greenhouse effect
on venus started about 1 billion years
ago so we know a lot more things about
venus
thanks to
many missions which went to venus such
as orbital emissions in the past decades
very small amounts of oxygen were
detected in the atmosphere by at least
two different separate independent
probes
and it's amazing because we also don't
know how oxygen would be made on venus
at the levels found and there's sort of
enough puzzles
that something really interesting is
happening on venus
recent probes to venus like the european
space agency's venus express and the
japanese aerospace exploration agency
zakatsuki has given us a lot of valuable
science
but only mars has had missions
specifically looking for organic
compounds the ingredients for life
then in 2020 this happened
it's an extraordinary possibility living
organisms floating in the clouds of
planet venus there may be some form of
life
on venus
this gas is called phosphite that what
exactly is it do we have any idea
a team led by astronomers in the uk
reported seeing the spectral signature
of phosphine in telescope data
phosphine's very unusual because on
earth it's only associated with life
either bacteria in oxygen free
environments like wetlands
or made by humans as pesticides and
other chemicals
suddenly there was a potential biomarker
for life in the venusian atmosphere and
this really changed a little bit the
picture of astrobiology research in our
solar system
while some groups have disputed the
claim saying that the phosphine signal
isn't there or at least at levels less
than previously thought it's
reinvigorated the interest in venus from
the public and scientific community so
despite all this controversy of
phosphine
people have started to re-look at the
old so-called legacy data
from the american and russian probes
that went into the venus atmosphere in
the late 70s and early 80s
and
what's very intriguing is it looks like
there's evidence for phosphine from
metal data
[Music]
one thing everyone can agree on is the
need for more research into venus
nasa and the european space agency
recently greenlit three separate
missions
veritas will map the planet's surface
in davinci plus the second nasa mission
will have an orbiter to image venus in
the ultraviolet and infrared light and
will send a probe through venus's
atmosphere
while the european space agency's
envision will take high-resolution radar
images of the planet's surface
although these missions will give us a
lot of valuable data
none of them are dedicated solely to
finding biomarkers
in order to really determine whether
there is life we would need to go there
and for us the question was immediately
how can we quickly develop and launch a
mission in order to determine whether
there's really life in the venusian
atmosphere or not and within
two weeks after the announcement of the
potential discovery of hospine we
published a report on this mission study
to deploy a fleet of balloons and the
venusian atmosphere and to search for
life
balloons are used for scientific studies
on earth due to their cheap cost simple
design and ability to stay in the
atmosphere for a long period of time
you can buy high altitude balloons for
maybe
a couple of hundred dollars or euros
they tend to be fairly robust so you
just launch them and then you can
essentially forget about them
and these are two
benefits which are also applicable to
the venusian context
and considering the technology already
exists it could be launched quickly
venusian
balloon which
consists essentially of
two basic elements so one is the balloon
sphere and then we have what we call a
chipset so it's about the size of a
credit card and we have a very small
payload such as a tiny camera or a small
microscope on board and all the
subsystems such as power supply and
communications etc
so far this proposal hasn't made it to
the hardware phase yet
but a separate study headed by professor
sarah seeger at mit and funded in part
by breakthrough initiatives is looking
at three separate missions
the first one to launch via rocket labs
rocket as early as 2023
we're really really absolutely thrilled
that we have a mission to venus
we've partnered with rocket lab to
supply the scientists science team and
science instrument
and there's room for like a tiny
instrument less than one kilogram
that will go on the probe
and the probe is going to drop through
the atmosphere
very quickly
so the probe would last maybe an hour
and going through the cloud layers that
we care about that will be about three
minutes
so this mission is short
and the instrument that the team chose
it has a kind of complicated name it's
called an autofluorescing nephelometer
autofluorescence refers to the fact that
we're basically shining ultraviolet
light on the droplets and looking for
any fluorescence that in other
wavelengths other colors of light
and then nephrometer is just a fancy
word for
an instrument that measures the light
that's scattered from particles if you
have a black light and you're out in the
desert and you shine on a scorpion the
scorpion lights up green colored just
like my piece of fluorescent plastic and
that demonstrates how
organic compounds life compounds could
be found on venus with fluorescence
the instrument
which in its final form will fit inside
of an estimated half a kg payload will
be the first attempt on venus to
specifically look for biomarkers
this instrument by itself is not going
to be able to definitely determine
that there's life on venus
but if we detect organic compounds in
the cloud droplets it's an indication
that there might be life
if what they find looks promising their
next mission would be a balloon mission
to look for biomarkers in different
areas of the atmosphere
we envision a balloon and we have a few
very very specific things we want to
measure
we'd like to re-measure the gases that
don't belong
including phosphine and ammonia and
oxygen
we'd like to check out these droplets in
more detail in particular we want to
measure the acidity of the droplets
because there's some new theories out
there
including one from my team that the
droplets aren't all uniform and that
they're not all incredibly acidic that
some might be a more friendly acidity to
life
and we'd also like to measure um more
details about the composition of the
droplets measure that directly
not just from light scattering
and if there are promising discoveries
from that mission
to ultimately prove microbes are present
they're proposing a third mission
we would go to venus with a balloon
and this balloon would have a miniature
rocket attached to it
and we would collect samples so we'd
condense the cloud particles and we
would trap some air on venus some of the
gases
and we would package those
um get it inside the rocket which would
launch from the balloon
and it would intercept with an orbiter
that would then be able to act as a
cruise vehicle to come home to earth
with these precious samples so that here
on earth we could use our very
sophisticated and exquisite instruments
to
look for life
these missions would be the first
balloon missions to look for life on
another planet but probably not the last
they're people who have been trying to
get a balloon mission to venus for
decades actually it's not like we came
and had all these brilliant ideas we're
obviously standing on the shoulders of
people before us you know people who are
still working on such missions but with
the rise of private space companies and
the miniaturization of technology
inexpensive balloon missions like these
could solve mysteries faster and make
space more accessible
there's a basic
human urge to find out if we are alone
but but it's also of tremendous
importance if we think about who would
find life on venus did it have same
origin as life on earth or did it really
emerge in
parallel and this has huge implications
also for us
as humanity
every society in human history appears
to have had astronomy as part of its
culture
and that is about wanting to know and
explore what is beyond earth
and today that question includes is
there life out
there i think it's part of wanting to
understand you know our place in the
universe
are we alone are we unique
or
is the universe filled with with other
life forms
you